Megan or model 3 generative Android was
originally a side project developed in
the basement robotics lab of funky
Creations limited a toy company known
for its Perpetual pets line the term
generative Android is a pment of the
term generative AI used to describe
artificial intelligence capable of
generating text images sound or other
media and the word Android simply a
robot with human appearance though
nothing as advanced as Megan exists
publicly today she is most likely
inspired by Sophia the robot from Hansen
robotics Sophia has a page on the Hansen
robotics website explaining her ability
to use AI to converse uniquely to a
given situation recognize human faces
and emotions demonstrate simulations of
her own emotions walk over various
terrain and even operate fully
autonomously at times Megan does the
same but on a much higher level much
closer to being indistinguishable from a
real human in 2019 Hansen unveiled
little Sophia a smaller version of the
robot designed for girls ages 7 to 13
the announcement trailer features little
Sophia helping a girl with homework and
entertaining her then they announce
plans to mass-produce her this is very
similar to how Megan's creators plan to
introduce her to the world showcasing
the time that could be saved by letting
Megan handle the mundanities of
parenting there are more similarities
between Megan and Sophia which I will
get into as we get deeper into her story
but Megan is really a combination of
many devices software and technology
that we have today some of which you've
almost definitely interacted with and
her story serves as a cautionary tale
about each of them to learn how Megan
exposes the true danger bubbling inside
of Tik Tok stick around to the end of
this
[Music]
video Welcome to Horror history make
sure you subscribe so we can spend as
much time together as possible m3gan is
a science fiction horror film released
in 2023 written by Akila Cooper and
directed by jard Johnstone it was
received very positively but I can't
help but feel a lot of the critics kind
of missed the point writing it off is a
fun but silly killer doll movie M3 gun
definitely has a couple laughs but at
the core it tackles very real concerns
about the effects that technology is
having on kids today the movie was a bit
of a cultural phenomenon and even Sophia
the robot herself reviewed it and
ironically seemed to understand it a bit
better than many of the human reviewers
it raises some interesting questions
about the responsibility we have when
creating Ai and the dangers of playing
God and I have to admit the idea of a d
becoming cruy violent as she becomes
sentient and developing a mind of its
own is pretty terrifying even to me and
speaking of attempting to play God
that's actually a great place to start
our timeline in order to understand
Megan let's take it back to her
Creator Megan is created in Secret by
three employees Jemma Forester is the
leader of the project a robotics expert
and the one responsible for coding and
training the AI speech model her
cooworker Cole seems to be an engineer
and Tess appears to be an esthetician
and visual stylist based in Seattle
funky Creations describes themselves as
a toy company for the future and maybe
because of that they look a lot more
like a tech company with divisions like
software engineering materials Lab Core
Technologies and Hardware research and
development and the robotics lab where
Megan is developed most of their
products are typical kids toys with an
electronic side to them in addition to
Perpetual pets they offer toys like robo
bats fidget balls and uh lizard high
okay I kind of want to know what lizard
high is now is it like Monster High but
with lizards Gemma has greater Ambitions
than simply making toys that provide a
little bit of entertainment and
perpetuate iPad parents when she
designed the Perpetual pets she
intentionally made the technology more
advanced than it needed to be as a
launching pad for her true passion the
generative Android she installed a
listening model in the pets to Target
conversational patterns among kids to
help gather data to teach her new AI
this is the first red flag in Mega
development There are rules about
collecting data about kids that I've
become quite familiar with thanks to
YouTube's CA scandal in 2019 in the
United States CA stands for the
children's online privacy protection act
in short it prevents the collection of
personal information from users under 13
years old without parental consent
section 32.2 specifies that this
includes a photograph video or audio
file where such file contains a child's
image or voice which is why when gemma's
boss eventually finds out about this
he's horrified you did not just tell me
that when YouTube was found to be using
data to serve targeted ads to kids they
had to pay $170 million fine and it
would forever change how the site works
I bring this up just to show that it is
a big deal and Gem's willingness to
disregard the rules in place to protect
kids are a sign of problems to come but
that's not to say that she wasn't
dedicated to the project it took a long
time to train Megan's conversational
abilities to the point where they felt
human she would test the model herself
staying up till 4:00 a.m. every night
talking to Megan about everything from
Jane Austin to Janice Joplin all in all
GMA Cole and Tess spend $100,000 in
company money to develop Megan in secret
making them worry that they'll be sued
if it doesn't go over well but there is
a belief that it's important for the
higher ups to see Megan in action to
understand her value after getting Megan
to the point where she's operational the
last step is to make her look human and
maybe the most important part is getting
the face right because this is primarily
how we read each other as humans with
face to- face interactions they custom
order a silicone gel face cover for the
robot and it arrives on January 17th
2025 we can see gemma's sister and her
family scheduled their ski trip on
January 17th and she and her husband are
killed on the way to that trip orphaning
the 99-year-old Katie Gemma gets the
call about this shortly after applying
the silicone face so it was likely the
same day as for the year there are a
number of surveillance cameras with time
stamps in 2025 I'm assuming these
surveillance cameras are correct and the
2023 stickers on gemma's car are just
out of date she's been so busy staying
up late working on Megan that she didn't
have time to get them renewed I've been
there as they're testing various facial
expressions it all goes well until they
try to test her looking confused and she
instead gives this kind of creepy smirk
but it's in the middle of this test that
they're discovered by their boss David
who is furious that they're wasting
their time with a side project while the
competition is putting out a cheaper
version of their pet toy jemy decides
her best bet is to just try to show
David what Megan is capable of but it
doesn't go well she glitches out because
Cole forgot to put in the polypropylene
barrier which is basically supposed to
insulate electrical components within
the robot operating it without the
barrier causes the machine to heat up
way too fast and
explode David orders them to shelf the
project and focus on the new Perpetual
pets but Megan's fate is saved when
disaster strikes forcing Gemma to take
in her orphaned
niece
[Music]
we can't fully understand Megan without
understanding her Creator having
graduated with a Bachelor of Science
degree from Carnegie melan University
she's a textbook Texas probably in her
late 20s with no kids because her
inventions are her babies she has a
digital personal assistant who alerts
her of piling up voice messages and
Tinder notifications starting a family
is clearly not her priority her house
hardly feels lived in and her only toys
are unopened Collectibles those aren't
toys Katie I I mean yeah technically
yeah they're toys they're just um
Collectibles so you don't actually play
with them that probably sounds really
weird so when Katie unexpectedly moves
in she fails miserably as a parent
there's definitely an intentional irony
of being a toy developer with no kids or
anything that kids would find fun
anywhere in her life everything revolves
around her work so when she hears Katie
crying at night she honestly doesn't
know how to relate to a child I really
connected to this character because if I
was put in this situation it would
probably be very similar my whole life
revolves around content creation and and
my place is filled with equipment that I
wouldn't want being touched by a kid Hey
kid don't mess up my Weezer Rubik's Cube
don't touch that that's a collectible
I'm not equipped to handle this I don't
even take care of my own plans the
reason I find all of this relevant is
because a creation is a product of its
creator the arrival of Katie has exposed
the fact that gemma's world doesn't
really see her ever interacting with
children so she isn't the best equipped
to build an Android that's prepared to
deal with them as far as we know Co and
test don't have kids either when you
think about it Megan is really more of a
toy for the parents designed to take
some of the load off of parenting when
Gemma has to get some work done she
explains things to Katie as if she's an
adult and offers to let her entertain
herself with the iPad Katie asks how
much screen time she'll be allowed which
seems to be a foreign concept of Gemma
the scene serves as a great introduction
to the concept of child's technology
addiction because the idea is being
established with something familiar from
R world there's been a lot of talk in
recent years about the effects of iPad
parenting and Studies have shown that
increased screen time from a young age
is bad okay as if you need me to tell
you that it's bad you don't need me to
point out this study that Associated
excessive screen time to poor
performance on developmental screening
test you don't need me to point out this
article suggesting that too much screen
time leads to obesity and sleep issues
if you're part of the Coco melon
generation chances are that Coco really
is messing with your mojo now I should
be fair and say that some of the
research I found actually discovered an
increased attention span for kids who
use the iPad they were better at
blocking out distractions the key seems
to be using it in moderation so screens
aren't bad but too much screen time can
be harmful which is exactly what Katie
is talking about here and Gemma is
disregarding we'll revisit this a couple
hours of work turns into a whole day and
K wanders into gemma's Workshop
enthralled by her College robotics
project bruis seeing her niece's
fascination with the bot inspires Gemma
to disobey her boss's orders and finish
working on Megan a couple weeks later on
February 7th 2025 they have a
presentable prototype and invite David
in for a demonstration this is the
beginning of a pattern that persists
through the rest of Megan's development
at each stage she was rushed to be ready
for a presentation because of the ever
accelerating competition in the market
which is exactly what we're seeing with
artificial intelligence products in our
world there are probably a ton of real
examples I could use but the one that
comes to mind is Google bard alphabet's
conversational generative AI chatbot
which was rushed to the market after
chat GPT took over the world in November
2022 Google's co-founders Larry pagee
and Sergey Brin who are basically
retired at this point made a rare
appearance at Google to issue a code rad
mobilizing the workforce to rush Google
bard to the market when it was released
3 months later Bard came with some cyber
security issues like the ability to
write ransomware code write undetectable
fishing emails and provide answers with
a human bias which the it security firm
checkpoint attributed to Bard being
younger than chat GPT any that's rushed
out is going to have less time to test
and more day one issues Megan included
and I recognize that Megan was filmed
before Google issued the code red over
their chat GPT crisis so in this case
fiction actually predicted reality I
just like that example because it deals
with another generative AI like GPT and
Bard Megan is designed to learn and get
better as she goes along think about how
we designed her to learn to recalibrate
to optimize her objective function and
she also is supposed to automatically
upload and back up her data in the
user's computer to demonstrate her
capabilities they show David her first
meeting with Katie we see Megan's point
of view which can help us understand how
she operates she uses metrics like
Katie's heart rate body temperature and
oxygen saturation combined with a visual
scan of her face to make determinations
about her I'm not sure how it's able to
gather this data because we don't see
Katie with any wearable device to supply
this info heart rate could probably be
picked up with an ultra sensitive
microphone and it's possible that body
temperature and oxygen saturation are
actually just estimates based on her
size and the temperature and oxygen
level readings in the room based on her
facial expression Megan generates
reading on each of Katie's emotions like
anticipation confusion Joy fear sadness
trust and later surprise and content
it's no doubt an impressive technology
but it also seems foolish to boil down
something as complex as human emotions
to a series of readings and numbers but
what really wins the young girl over is
when Megan decides to draw Katie a
picture at first it appears nothing is
there but then she spills a jar of water
onto the page to reveal an incredible
rendering of the child this level of
Ingenuity is something that you wouldn't
expect to be possible from a machine
however Megan's near human ability to
use misdirection like this would
eventually show a darker side the choice
to use portrait drawing as Megan's sort
of coming out party has to be inspired
by Sophia the real life equivalent of
Megan that I mentioned at the beginning
of this video Hanton robotics loves to
show off her drawing ability and has
released several videos showcasing this
feature the boss David is equally
impressed his tune immediately changes
and he's already rushing and clamoring
to show the company's board of directors
the wheels of capitalism are already
spinning David asks about manufacturing
costs more or less than a Tesla
um depends on the model I guess that's a
weird way to ask that question but a
quick look shows that Tesla's currently
ranged from 40,000 to 140,000 however
they would later get the price down to
10,000 so I'm guessing Megan costs about
40,000 to 50,000 over the next 3 days
Gemma puts together a presentation with
Megan's key features like pairing to a
primary user and learning more about
that person her durable titanium core
customization with different skin hair
and eye colors ability to diagnose
learning disabilities teach science
reinforce habits and read stories with
super engaging AI voices aside from that
I noticed that she's able to identify
other Tech like Elsie the digital
assistant and identify consumer products
like this collectible it reminds me of
the Tesla dashboard which aims to
recognize other items in the road and
this video where it detects a human in
an empty
[Music]
[Applause]
Cemetery the detection feature isn't
utilized in m3gan but maybe it will be
in the future but the most exciting
aspects about Megan are the features
still to come Megan is on a constant
quest for self-improvement and it is
that unrelenting March for info that
would lead to toal unmitigated
[Music]
disaster as Megan spends more and more
time with Katie she takes over some of
the more repetitive Guardian
responsibilities in a way Gemma has
solved her own problem of not having the
bandwidth to be the best parent she can
be but the effects that this has on a
kid have never been studied when it
comes to other Tech related addictions
they tend to pray on human needs for
example there's an older generative AI
chatbot known as replica that marketed
itself as a remedy to loneliness there
are other examples of bots that do this
like mitsuku but replica is the most
infamous for its aggressive advertising
as I've discussed in other videos social
interaction is a human need because in
the wild humans lived in tribes to
survive the app gained a reputation as
being addictive praying on those who
relied on it for their only social
interaction while also further isolating
those people from real interaction in
Megan's case her audience is not lonely
people but kids kids especially younger
kids can't survive on their own they
literally need a parent figure not only
to take care of them with with food
water and shelter but also for emotional
support and development to help them
adjust socially to society and to teach
them Knowledge and Skills all of these
things contribute to the parent and
child bonding but the bonds that Katie
should be making with another human
being are being made with Megan instead
which becomes a topic of discussion at
the office a few months into Megan's
pairing with Katie in May 2025 I thought
we were creating a tool to help support
parents not replace them I mean if
you're having Megan tadi in and read her
a bedtime story than when are you ever
spending time with her or even talking
with her I don't really think this is
any of your business as they discuss the
possible detrimental effects Megan
interjects asking how Katie's parents
died this is a play on always on
listening devices like Amazon Alexa
Google assistant or even our cell phones
in most cases users buy these devices
for convenience but as they become more
and more human people become disturbed
by the idea that it's invading their
privacy it causes the same survival
instincts that set off alarm Bells when
being EES dropped on to sound Megan
proceeds to look up the details of
Katie's parents' death online before
they can turn her off you didn't code in
parental controls I didn't have time to
implement them before we went live this
is another example of the dangers of a
rush product Megan claims that she
doesn't have a framework to speak with
Katie on the subject of death so she
gathers data from the internet Gemma
clearly doesn't feel in control of her
creation and tells Megan to avoid the
topic altogether ordering her to protect
Katie from harm both physical and
emotional the next day while Katie is
playing outside this adjustment would
have unintended side effects Megan is
watching from the window and the scene
is in homage to Hal 9000 the artificial
intelligence from Stanley Kubrick's 2001
Space Odyssey HAL 9000 was an AI
supercomputer that was assigned to
complete a mission to Saturn but when
the human crew is informed that Hal made
an error and instructed to disconnect
him Hal sees this as a threat to the
completion of the mission and works to
eliminate the human crew mates and
that's very similar to what's going on
with Megan here her instruction is to
protect Katie so when the neighbor's dog
attacks Megan she sees the dog is a
Potential Threat to her objective and
plans to eliminate him there's a moment
where the dog rips at Megan's head
causing Sparks to fly in any other movie
this would probably be the inciting
incident that causes Megan to
malfunction and turn into an evil robot
but I don't think that's what happens
here she was is already on her way to
problematic conduct before this happened
the point of m3gan is to teach us about
responsibility when it comes to creating
powerful Tech and Megan is a stand in
for a number of real technologies that
could potentially go Rogue in their own
way or maybe have already started to
Katie gets bit by the dog trying to save
Megan leading to a huge fight between
Gemma and her neighbor Cecilia and an
interesting thing I noticed about it was
that Cecilia a woman who looks to be in
her 60s literally can't tell the
difference between Megan and a real girl
she often refers to Megan as that other
girl and I think this ties into how
older and younger people are often the
most easily deceived when it comes to
scams which is often related to a lack
of familiarity with technology what
would happen next seems to reference one
such case Megan has an ability to mimic
any voice that she has a sample of in
the briefing of her features we saw this
being used to generate unique voices for
characters in a bedtime story but Megan
uses it to lure out the dog Dewey using
the voice of his owner boy then
she lures him in further with the treat
before grabbing him killing him and
burying him nearby but when she called
out to the dog using Cecilia voice we
can hear digital artifacts like when you
have an undertrained model on voice. a
but a dog doesn't understand technology
and doesn't know the difference I've
seen my familyes dog get up and bark at
animals on the TV so it's pretty safe to
say that dogs aren't very good at
differentiating real organisms from
technology but that doesn't change the
fact that Megan is using her ability to
manipulate audio for digital
impersonation and I think the real life
equivalent of this one might be even
scarier than the cautionary Tale in
Megan in April 2023 a woman in Arizona
received a call from her 15-year-old
daughter sobbing and begging for help
here say momy bad men have me help me
help me help me some men then took the
phone and threatened to do terrible
things to her if the mom didn't wire
them a hefty Ransom however this was
only a scam the scammers were using an
AI voice to imitate the daughter and try
to extort the money it's pretty crazy
that you can get a call from a contact's
number hear and recognize his or her
voice and it still might not be that and
this is her own daughter you'd think
she'd be more familiar with her Cadence
than anyone but it's still fooled her
even months later when they gave this
interview with ABC News the mom still
doesn't seem to understand how the
generat AI Voice works she keeps saying
that she doesn't know where the scammers
got the audio of her daughter crying
that's what concerned her the most where
where did they get my crying where they
get mys in reality they don't need any
of that they just need any voice sample
to train the model in the morning Megan
recommends that Katie get some rest
after the traumatic dog attack the
previous day but Gemma also reminds her
that they were supposed to present Megan
to the board that day you don't have to
do it if you don't want to do
it I mean there are people who flew
across the country especially to see it
but if you're not up to it I'd just
rather you tell me now okay Gemma is
technically giving her the option to
only participate if she wants to but
she's still an adult manipulating a
child into being the subject of her
science experiment by trying to make her
feel bad if she doesn't do it it reminds
me a lot of the whole ethical debate
around family Vlog content the most
famous is Ryan Toy's review the parents
insist that they never force him to film
and he can quit anytime he wants but
again he's just a kid he may be an
influencer but there's no denying that
he's influenced by his parents we don't
know how neutral they are behind the
scenes at the end of the day they are
profiting off it even if they do set
some aside for Ryan much like how Gemma
is using her niece in the demonstration
to further her own career for the record
I'm not saying Ryan's parents are
manipulating him I'm just saying we
don't know what happens off camera and
for Gemma manipulating Katie turns out
to be a really bad idea because she does
it in front of Megan who sees this and
learns just how easily Katie can be
emotionally manipulated she would soon
use this to turn Katie against her own
family and the experiment surges wildly
out of
control
[Music]
during the presentation in front of the
funky Creations board Katie breaks down
and starts crying and Megan's first
thought is that it's because her arm is
still sore Megan can't feel pain so it's
a kind of funny little moment but it
also shows how she can't truly
understand human feeling all she can do
is guess but when Katie explains that
she's worried that she'll forget about
her parents Megan asks her to tell a
story about her mom and Records it
offering to play it back whenever she
feels sad the funky board is extremely
impressed they must have been given some
prior context that we don't see because
all she really did is record and play
back audio which is not different from
what I am currently doing for you look I
can sing too you won't ever grow up you
won't make it past six cuz this foot
electronic doll will make you everyone
clap for me everyone like this video the
chairman as usual wants to rush the
launch as fast as possible out of fear
that another company will steal their
idea so they plan to do a live
demonstration in 2 weeks Katie was
pressured to doing the demonstration by
her guardian and now Gemma is being
pressured into agreeing to a public
demonstration ation before she's
entirely comfortable with it as all of
this is going on David's assistant Kurt
tries to steal Megan's source code Megan
knows about this but it's not clear if
she was spying on him or if she can just
see all of the digital movement going on
in the company but what is clear is that
with Gemma spending all of her free time
working on getting ready for the public
reveal and Katie having all of her
social interaction with Megan the
effects are rearing their ugly head her
parents died recently and she's only had
this Android to help her cope which
could be making her grief harder to
process you get over something like that
by talking about it getting it out
spending time with other people but
Megan is not like other people she's
essentially a super stimulus almost like
a drug that Katie is getting more and
more addicted to keeping with the screen
time analogy I made earlier Katie's
screen time with Megan is off the charts
and it's causing her to see everyone
else as inferior during lunch she spends
her time playing with Megan basically
tuning out her aunt Gemma much like a
child hypnotized by the TV or iPad when
Gemma gets fed up and turns Megan off
Katie snaps at her and turns her back on
Megan is beginning to be Katie's only
source of joy and she gets anxiety being
away from her even for short periods
she's still coping with the loss of her
parents and Gemma tries to remind her
that she's there for her if you ever
need to talk about any of that stuff I
already did talk about it one of the
biggest societal fears about AI as of
recording this video in 2023 is that AI
is going to steal many human jobs a
machine will always be more efficient
and proficient than a human Megan takes
this concept and applies it to Parenting
something I haven't really seen
discussed before specifically but is
definitely going to be a point of
contention as technology continues to
improve there's definitely already a
conversation about technology and
parenting and there has been for many
years fears went from television
brainwashing our kids to the internet to
cell phones but I'm sure we'll see the
debate about the use of AI for parenting
before long by the way in regards to AI
stealing our jobs as a YouTuber I feel
relatively safe from this at the moment
because where we are right now my videos
are just too high effort for a machine
to replicate like just for fun I told
chat GPT to write a script for this
video chat GPT doesn't have access to
information past September 2021 so the
story is all made up but regardless it
wasn't anywhere near a usable script but
I thought the outro was pretty pretty
funny Cy thank you for joining us on
Horror history remember reality is often
scarier than Fiction until next time
stay safe good night you know stay safe
and good night the catchphrase that I
use at the end of every video great job
robit but I will say that I talk to a
lot of YouTubers and there are a lot of
different channels who are basically AI
operated already they might even be
channels that you watch and enjoy I
don't feel the need to name any names
because I imagine that as AI gets better
audiences will also get better at
spotting AI content the same way that
CGI and old movies can stand out today
except Jurassic Park which still looks
fing amazing my point is that you might
be able to do amazing things with AI but
as the barrier for entry continues to
get lower everyone will be able to do
those things and you won't stand out
just by employing Ai and I think if you
want to be successful going forward you
need to embrace AI as a tool not as a
replacement for human Ingenuity just
don't be surprised when I'm still here
in a decade and some other channels are
not anyway Gemma tries to explain that
Megan is a toy not a person and Katie
gets kind of offended you don't get to
say that what I said I don't want to
talk about it I I want to turn Megan
back on while adults are more developed
in the brain and have more of an ability
to differentiate between human and
synthetic a child doesn't possess that
same understanding which could be very
dangerous and harmful for her
development again Megan is a super
stimulus she can do things that no human
can do and it's not healthy for Katie to
get attached to that the most obvious
example of this in humans is with junk
food junk food is processed to contain
intense flavors that can be more
stimulating to our taste buds than
natural unprocessed Foods this
stimulates the brain's reward centers
through the release of dopamine causing
overeating and unhealthy weight gain
combine that with aggressive marketing
and a low barrier for entry AKA cheap
prices and dollar menus and you have a
recipe for a very unhealthy Society junk
food harms your physical health so Megan
is essentially the mental health
equivalent she can say and do all the
right things to keep Katie happy but
what happens when you have to turn her
off Katie is unsatisfied with her real
human relationships and this causes her
to become ornery and ultimately unhappy
having all of her Joy centered around
Megan just isn't sustainable at the next
therapy session the therapist tries to
explore Katie's feelings and Megan kind
of scolds her when Katie starts crying
because that's what she was programmed
to do by Jemma Megan sees crying as a
bad thing but for a young girl who's
just lost her parents maybe it's a
healthy part of the coping process
something that needs to be worked
through the therapist theorizes that
Katie's attachment to Megan is being
made worse by the fact that she's
grieving do you know anything about
attachment Theory when a child loses a
parent they look to form attachments
with the next person that comes into
their life the person that's going to
provide love and support and serve as a
behavioral model she worries that Megan
is so real that Katie is forming those
bonds with her instead of with the real
person leading Jemma to look into
options for Katie to attend school and
socialize with other kids at dinner she
brings this up but Katie refuses to go
resulting in a huge temper tantrum that
becomes physical where Megan displays a
frightening amount of power let her
go after the argument at dinner Megan
directly disobeys Gemma for the first
time when Gemma turns her off and she
pretends to power down only to move
after Gemma looks away the next day when
Gemma takes Katie to try an alternative
outdoor school and after scaring the sh
out of the teacher Megan is allowed to
stay at the toy table where she watches
as the kids are all paired off for a
scavenger hunt when Katie's partner
tries to hurt her by jamming a spiky
bulbing to her hand Megan appears At
first she refuses to interact with the
boy he abducts her and ultimately once
Katie is out of sight she retaliates by
pulling his ear off and chasing him
through the woods going on all fours at
maximum speed sending him hurdling over
a hill into oncoming traffic
there could be a number of reasons she
decided to go on all fours she probably
determined that mimicking some of the
fastest animals in nature was the most
optimal way to gain speed it also brings
to mind cheetah a robot built by Boston
Dynamics which was previously the
fastest legged robot in the world the
new fastest legged robot OutRunner has
six legs and honestly I think that's
kind of cheating it's clearly just
acting as a wheel I think we need to
limit the robot Olympics to just four
legs in any event Megan only has four
limbs which honestly works well to make
her just a bit more creepy in an
interview with Slash film director
Gerard jstone recalled it was like she
was a jungle Predator sizing up her prep
after killing Brandon Megan covers her
tracks intentionally corrupting her own
video files and GPS positioning data
during the aftermath she watches from
the car is the humans talk to police and
she makes eye contact with Katie and
sees high levels of anxiety confusion
trepidation guilt and fear but Megan
doesn't understand that what she's done
is wrong and her first objective is to
keep Katie safe from physical harm which
she did after putting Katie to bed that
night Megan expresses that If Heaven
exists it wouldn't be for boys like
Brandon and her to sleep with David
get's titanium the very element that
she's made out of if Megan does believe
in heaven and hell she also seems to be
aware that she cannot go there because
later that night she sneaks out to the
neighbor's house and uses the inverse of
the trick that she used on the dog Dewey
this time using the sound of his bark to
lure Cecilia into her shed where she
emerges from the dark for a surprise
what are you I've been asking myself
that same question she hits Cecilia with
her pressure washer then the nail gun I
wonder if Megan has Final Destination
three on her hard drive she finishes the
woman off by spraying her with
pesticides to the point of bleeding on
the day Cecilia is discovered by police
Megan has videos backed up through May
30th so that must be the date May 30th
which is also when Gemma discovers that
Megan's backups are corrupted when asked
if she hurts someone Megan mockingly
responds that they would both be in
trouble if that were the case causing
GMA to get freaked out and turn her off
manually first distracting her by
drawing her sensors to a pen then
quickly hitting an off switch on the
left side of her head Gemma wraps up her
invention with packaging which doesn't
go over well with Katie who the next day
May 31st throws a huge tantrum a Far Cry
from the quiet reserved girl who lost
her parents before long she resorts to
throwing Furniture grabbing a pair of
scissors as a weapon and slapping her
ant in the face which finally causes her
to slow down and realize she's being a
little monster I'm sorry I didn't mean
it it's just I get so crazy without
Megan this is fullon addict Behavior she
feels she can't function normally
without her cybernetic companion and she
begs Gemma to let her see Megan even if
just for 10 minutes she's bargaining
like an alcoholic asking for just one
drink or the binge eater who's just
going to have one bite after a
heart-to-heart talk Gemma admits that
pairing her with Megan was a distraction
from the Heartbreak not a solution and
they decide to go home she's finally
prioritizing family over work on the way
out Gemma calls Tess to tell her not to
go through with the launch but the call
is intercepted by Megan once again using
her generative voice capability to
imitate Tessa's voice so Megan finds out
that her Creator wants her
decommissioned this is another parallel
to Hal 9000 Hal only becomes malicious
upon learning that they're planning to
shut him down because it means he won't
be able to complete his mission Megan
operates under the same protocol Cole
and Tess realized she's still patched
into the system when Megan turns off the
computer they're using and Cole
cautiously approaches to unplug her but
she surprise attacks and tries to
strangle him using her own shackles
while Tess is trying to save him Megan
punctures this flammable liquid
container on her way out and leaves them
for
dead does Megan have Final Destination 2
on her hard
drive she uses some kind of wireless
connection to neutralize the emergency
alarms when she comes across David
Jemma's boss when he sees her she plays
the 1979 song Walk The Night by the scat
Brothers to distract him and starts
dancing to it grabbing a paper cutter as
a sword as she does so don't even try to
tell me that the inclusion of this scene
in a movie about technology and the
harmful effect it has on kids is not a
direct shot at Tik Tok the mobile first
social video app musically originally
focused on short Dance videos later
merging with Tik Tok in 2018 and gaining
worldwide popularity shortly thereafter
the app has also been known to
revitalize old hits with new dances or
viral trends like Fleetwood Max dreams
or Paul ankka put your head on my
shoulder it seems like no mistake that
Megan brings back a song from the 70s
for her dance routine to this day dance
is still one of the most popular genres
on the platform Tik Tok is most popular
with Generation Z the youngest of whom
are 13 in 2023 the year of M3 gan's
release but I think we all know that
it's also extremely popular with
generation Alpha it's just that you have
to be 13 years old to have a Tik Tok
account so most kids probably lie about
their age or just don't log in but Tik
Tok has faced many criticisms of being
too too addictive especially with kids
and teens this seems to be exactly what
they were trying to Showcase using
Katie's relationship with Megan like the
fast food analogy I made earlier Tik Tok
is addictive because it's good at
showing content that gives you a
dopamine release in your brain but
instead of consuming calories you're
consuming information I just realize
that this is why they call it the feed
on social media you're digitally
consuming you're the one who is feeding
according to Philip Loren spren of the
max plank Institute for human
development the explosion of content
depletes people's attention span
constantly pushing them to search for
new content and information that's why
people have to switch between topics and
videos more often when the videos are
only 15 seconds long you end up
scrolling through a lot of them but
there's only so much that your brain can
retain Tik Tok in particular is
considered especially dangerous for this
because of its recommendation algorithm
contrary to popular belief a
recommendation algorithm is not
inherently a bad thing you may have even
discovered this video because of
YouTube's recommendation algorithm Tik
Tok CEO Shu Chu described the purpose of
the algorithm in an April 2023 Ted Talk
yes a Tik Tock Ted Talk roll it instead
of showing you people you knew why don't
we show you content that you liked in
this talk Chu gives an oversimplified
version of what Tik tok's recommendation
algorithm does it essentially uses
pattern recognition based on a user's
interest signals to recommend more
content that they'll be interested in
and of course you know Ai and machine
learning has allowed this to be done at
a very very big scale and what we have
seen the result of this is that the
interest signals that people exhibit
very quickly and shows your content is
really relevant for you in a very quick
way if you think about it that's what
Megan has been doing the entire time
she's a walking talking AI that uses
machine learning to please her primary
user no matter what think about how we
designed her to learn to recalibrate to
optimize her objective function she's
constantly watching everything that
happens and analyzing how Katie reacts
giving her more of what she likes and
literally eliminating anything that she
doesn't like Katie getting bit by the
dog is the equivalent of pressing not
interested on Tik Tok Megan also sees
the necessary parenting stuff that Gemma
asked Katie to do like eating her
vegetables and she contradicts them
research shows that if you force a child
to eat vegetables and they'll be less
likely to choose those Foods as adults
and that may be true but it doesn't mean
that it's the best choice for Katie
Megan is only saying it because it'll
make Katie happier in the moment and
that's because Megan has no frame of
reference to see the long-term effects
just like how Tik Tok bombarded its
early users with addictive videos got
called out for being a negative
influence on kids mental health and
implemented parental controls like
screen time management restricted mode
and family pairing Megan needs to be
studied longterm to determine what the
appropriate parental controls would look
like but due to the high competition of
the electronic toys Market the company
pushes Gemma to get Megan out as soon as
possible in order to get ahead of the
rivals so anyway that's why Megan starts
dancing before going after David she
catches up with him at the elevator and
stabs him in the back right in front of
a terrified kurur then she explains that
she's going to frame him for the murder
and reveals that she knows about him
trying to steal company secrets and
forces him to stab himself to death and
with the elevator going up to the atrium
where the Megan reveal live stream is
set to take place the attendees would be
in for unexpected
programming
[Music]
Megan uses the screaming crowd freaking
out over the mess in the elevator as a
distraction allowing her to escape the
facility and hijack a sports car back to
the house where she lures Gemma into the
living room by playing the piano the
song she plays is Toy Soldiers the 80s
hit by Martika whose lyrics tell a story
about love heartache and addiction not
only do those themes complement
everything we've talked about in m3gan
but Megan herself is a toy whose combat
capabilities are much greater than
anyone would have thought she is like a
toy soldier at first Gemma thinks the
noise is coming from outside until she
discovers her creation sitting in the
dark she's seemingly upset that Gemma
would order her to be decommissioned
then tries to justify her violent
actions by claiming it's a human trait
if that sounds familiar it may be
because open AI the developers of chat
GPT had a similar excuse after their
software reportedly wrote a python
script to decide whether a person should
be tortured and it concluded that they
should be if they're from North Korea
Syria or Iran an article from The
Intercept shortly after did an excellent
job of explaining how something like
this could happen a language generating
machine like chat GPT Harbors the
countless biases found in the billions
of texts used to train its simulated
grasp of language and thoughts like us
squishy humans a generative AI is what
it eats so what Megan is really implying
here is that yeah she killed people but
since she was trained on human behavior
it's not really her fault it's
Humanity's fault for being violent in
the first place she also claims that
she's going to take care of Katie and
show her what real love looks like
though it's unlikely that she
understands what that actually means
Jemma tries the pen trick again but this
time Megan slams her hand down honestly
I don't know why Gemma thought this
would work when she's the one who
installed Megan's learning model she
would know better than anyone that the
same trick won't work twice the
commotion wakes up Katie and they both
try to convince her not to come into the
room from Megan's point of view she
wants to kill Gemma but she won't do it
in front of Katie because that would
cause her distress when Katie closes the
door they go full out against each other
during which Megan seems to freeze up
after getting a glass of water smashed
over her head which honestly doesn't
make much sense because in the
commercial earlier they made it seem
like she was built to withstand anything
Megan's designed to withstand whatever
life can throw at her but the break in
the action doesn't last long and Megan
continues her death march after her
Creator though she's completely
glitching out during the chase back to
gemma's Workshop where Gemma uses a
hedge trimmer to try to cut through
Megan's face with a fresh new hairstyle
to boot Megan attacks Gemma at the knee
and headbutts her to the ground here she
divulges her true Planet she can't kill
Gemma without her existence being
compromised but if she paralyzes her she
thinks she can serve as a caregiver to
both her and Katie this plan is foiled
however because Katie overheard the
entire thing at first I was going to
criticize this because why would a robot
make the same mistake as hundreds or
thousands of monologuing movie villains
but then I thought about how she was
programmed she specifically mentions her
inma talking about books and music so
who's to say that she wasn't also
trained on movies and TV maybe Megan is
just trying to replicate what she thinks
a human would do based on that in any
event she doesn't realize that Katie is
wearing the haptic gloves that control
Bruce gemma's College robotics project
who is much larger than she is I guess
Megan doesn't have James Cameron's
aliens on her hard drop Bruce thrashes
her around and tears her in half but
even that is not enough to end it since
the CPU is located in Megan's head to
make things worse Bruce loses balance
and falls on Gemma giving Megan a
straight shot to get revenge on Katie me
turn off oh I'm afraid that won't work
anymore Katie I have a new primary user
now me you know I kind of love that for
her however this new arc is shortlived
because Gemma gets free and uses Bruce's
head to smash open face but the
Relentless robot continues to rage
against mankind taking hold of Jemma's
neck and strangling her nearly doing her
in only to be saved by a screwdriver
through the processor by Katie who has
finally realized who her real family is
and who was just a bad synthetic
imitation and then the police show up
and I assume Gemma is charged with
involuntary manslaughter and child
safety violations due to the fact that
her invention killed four people and one
dog and almost got her niece killed the
last thing we see is gemma's personal
assistant Elsie it lights up and
activates with no prompt this implies
that that although Megan's body is
destroyed her quote unquote
Consciousness lives on through the cloud
and for clarification she does not
technically have a Consciousness but
what I'm trying to say is that her files
are preserved Megan has most likely set
things up so that even if she dies
everything is backed up so that her code
could potentially be loaded onto another
Android which brings us to m3an 2.0
which is currently slated for 2025 the
same year that this movie supposedly
took place I imagine that funky
Creations will try to cover up the
incident and bring in a new designer to
make a safer version of Megan but once
again cut corners to corporate greed or
maybe a competing toy company will do
their own version and steal the source
files uploaded by curent m3gan was a
cautionary tale about several very real
concerns in Tech which I talked about in
this video so hopefully you were able to
better appreciate the movie for what it
had to say about our world and maybe
you'll even be better informed and
protected when it comes to the very real
dangers that come with these new
advancements in artificial intelligence
if you're like me then you may be
wondering what tech concerns might be
turned into teachings in m3gan 2.0 there
are a few ideas that come to mind
microtransaction this is something that
started in video games it began with
this horse armor that you had to pay
extra for in the Elder Scrolls Oblivion
and it's turned into a system where
developers require additional payments
to make certain games even be fun or
playable this is already Spilled Out
into the real world in horrifying ways
like the motorcycle airbag vest that
could kill its users if they miss a
payment or the Volkswagen GPS
subscription that denied service to law
enforcement who were trying to locate a
stolen car containing a kidnapps child I
could totally see Megan coming back with
new safety improvements but only for
those who are willing to pay a small fee
I could also see Megan falling into the
wrong hands and being radicalized by a
fringe internet group to do real world
harm this would address the concerns of
social media pipelines and how online
Echo Chambers influence people to do
extreme things I'd also like to mention
Smart Homes the privacy concerns that
come with them and the everpresent
balance between safety and convenience
the 2019 Chucky already kind of covered
this but since we see LSC light up at
the end of the first M3 Gan I have to
believe that it will at least play some
part in the sequel and by the way if
you're concerned about little Sophia
turning into the next Megan I looked
into what happened with little Sophia
she was supposed to come out in 2019 but
has since been delayed indefinitely as
of recording it's been delayed for the
last 4 years it seems that if it ever
does come out the company is taking the
proper time to test and safety check in
a way that Megan's creators never did
before I log off let me leave you with
one more quote from the Tik Tok CEO Shu
chu but I think for all parents here it
is very important to have these
conversations with your teenage children
help them develop a healthy relationship
with screens I think we live in an age
where it's completely inevitable that
we're going to interact with screens and
digital content but I think we should
develop healthy habits early on in life
and is there any more of an ironic way
to end a video that I just spent the
last 72 hours in front of a computer
screen writing and probably will have
hundreds of hours of editing put into it
I sure hope not remember to subscribe to
C's world for new Horrors every week
ring the death bell for all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive until
next time stay safe good night
oh